no roads
let's see you can make it son i feel
safer already
i will take a secret service agent any
day
over anything like that hi everyone my
name is evie pomperis
i'm a former special agent with the u.s
secret service
and i was also on the presidential
protective division for
barack obama and first lady michelle
obama
i've also protected presidents george
h.w bush
george bush and bill clinton today i'm
going to be watching movies and tv clips
and letting you know how real or not
real
i think that they are
[Applause]
the first thing i noticed with this clip
is the president of the united states
is in the crowd shaking hands with
people that would really not happen
in real life when we're doing protection
you won't see the president go into the
crowd or into the table area
typically a rope line is created within
some distance from the stage usually
several feet
and people will line up by that rope
line and
the president will go then and shake
those people's hands so
there's always a barrier there's always
something separating
the president from the people he
or she may be in the future but he will
not be in that crowd
[Music]
that's not make believe that is very
very real
that is your job as a secret service
agent your job is to take a bullet not
only just to jump in front of the bullet
but to get into the way and to make
yourself as
big as possible so you're also taught to
expand your body
to make sure that the bullet actually
hits you and doesn't miss you
and hit the president of the united
states through all the tactical training
that you go through in the secret
service academy this is a movement that
you do
over and over and over again it's also a
secret service mindset
when you go through training and if you
enter this job like you are at that
point
comfortable and fully okay with doing
something like this
the shift's job is to assess the
environment they're always looking out
and the potential threat
is someone who can do harm the number
one thing to look for honestly is the
hands you want to see hands and i always
would want to see hands open hands
so if the hands are out and open then i
know that there's nothing in those
hands on occasion you might get somebody
who unintentionally is maybe holding
something holding
even a pen and when you see that i mean
literally
you just knock that pen out of their
hands if somebody has their hands in
their pockets and they're unwilling to
take them out if there's not enough time
to get those hands out i mean you
literally would just grab that person's
hands
lock them down until the president
passes
based on realism on 1-10 i would
actually give this
i would give this a seven
mr secretary get away from the window
now we need to leave now
we see the detail leader go over to
where
kiefer sutherland is standing and he
actually closes
the windows and he tells them sure get
away from the window that is absolutely
correct that is
absolutely what i would do as well you
would want to get them out of the area
danger
and you'd want to put them in an
environment where they are safe some
type of bunker
did you see that right now did you see
that smoke out in the ambush
white house is secure let's go i would
not
take the future president of the united
states
back to the white house absolutely not
the swearing-in ceremony can wait till
later
you'd want to take the president to an
undisclosed
safe location keep him there for some
time
until things have settled and then you
can figure out what to do next so on 9
11 what did they do with the president
they grabbed the president
and they actually kept him on air force
one and they flew around
it's confirmed the eagle is gone
in the scene we see the president being
referred to as eagle his code
name every administration gets code
names and typically
the code names all begin with the same
letter so for the clintons
it was an e everybody in the clinton
administration or the protectees they
all had
ease for president george w bush it was
a t
and so essentially all the family
members first lady president
the children they all had code names
beginning with the team
so they do change for every
administration and the code name
actually
stays with the person even after they
leave
the presidency
where are my snipers snipers are there
to actually look for the threat that's
coming from above here we see an open
window
the snipers are tactically placed
throughout the environment and they're
put in elevated positions so they can
see
elevated threats so they're actually
working in tandem with a ground
team and they call out the positions
they call out the threats
the ground team is what responds they
are active they are seeing
open window they are seeing somebody
moving they are seeing somebody at a
rooftop
and immediately somebody is responding
your sniper team up top is the one who's
gonna see the threat
they're gonna engage the threat and
they're gonna take that threat
out on a scale of one to ten i would
give this one a three
i have a really hard time with this clip
because there's so many things in here
that are not true which makes kind of
the whole
thing not real the cars the cars the
cars the beast there's only one beast in
this
there's always going to be two beasts
and not only are you going to have two
ballistic limos you're also going to
have multiple
follow-up vehicles which tend to be
suburban which are
also ballistic your emergency vehicle
which is showing up to save the day
that's going to be there you're not
going to have this emergency vehicle
showing up
from nowhere now here we also see this
internal ambush happening
in the inner circle of the president
although we have help you have police
help
they typically tend to be at the
outskirts in the inner circle
of protection it's always going to be
u.s secret service so here's why there's
a technical error here
the building we see the building
somebody closes the doors that would
never happen there's always an agent
there and that
agent's job is to make sure that those
doors are open so that the president can
run back in if they he needs to the
other thing is the vehicle door that
vehicle door will also stay open so
basically what you're insuring is the
president can either go into the car
if he needs to into the beast or back
into the building
and here we see them stuck outside which
should absolutely
never happen
that is a ballistic vehicle the beast is
called the beast for a specific
reason the beast is designed to take a
beating
and keep going when you travel to
another country
you make sure to do advanced work
advanced work means
sending agents out there in advance
for weeks at a time sometimes maybe even
a month
to prepare for a visit that means you
work very closely
with the local police department the
local law enforcement entities the local
intelligence entities
it is the proactive element it's
everything you've done beforehand so
when i see this image i have a problem
where are my snipers
should be snipers there where's the
tactical team there should be a tactical
team there
were the long weapons secret service
shift agents also have long weapons
where
are those i want to give it a zero but
let's give it
um i would give it a two
this way man
nicholas cage is actually trying to get
tess
to get in through his door the passenger
side door
what he's doing is correct typically you
will see the protectee
going in through that specific door the
door behind the passenger
and we see the detail leader which is
nicholas cage in this part
sitting in the front seat the door
that's closest to her front door
is the passenger side door of the
vehicle
a protectee needs to go in through the
closest door so what's the closest door
to my front door
that passenger side door the issue here
is you don't want the protectee coming
out the front door
then walking around the vehicle through
the other side
that's the issue there ma'am excuse me
but we are not leaving this house until
you are seated properly with your seat
belt firmly
fastened you have to lay the law down
and
i probably would have done what nicholas
cage did
[Music]
your duty is to physically protect them
but you're also there to shield them for
many things
i definitely would not do what he did
kind of shaking her up like that
but i would nudge her i would maybe draw
the
the curtains down at the side and shield
her i would give it
an 8.
yeah there's a lot of issues with it
that's one one
is how on earth did he end up in the
middle there with his protectee
that's i want to say impossible but
that's highly highly highly unlikely why
is there so much difference between the
vehicles and them the vehicles should
actually pull up
super close to them to shield them my
other thing is we see the first lady
in this movie jump out which is played
by kim bassinger
she jumps out and she's the middle of it
where's her detail leader
each protectee has a detail leader
meaning the president has their own
person who protects them
and their shift and then the first lady
has the
her own person who protects her her
detail leader
and her shift so there's two protection
elements
not one so we do see michael douglas
call out formations or degrees or angles
as to where he wants people to go
that's not something that we do there
are formations and these are
pre-choreographed pre-designed
formations that we use and we know
when and how to use them and the detail
leader can on occasion sporadically call
them out
but when we are being attacked everybody
automatically knows
where to go and everybody has their own
position depending on the type
of attack on a scale of one to ten i
would give it
a three
no roads let's see you can make it son
i feel safer already one
why isn't he id'd i mean make him lift
up his mask i don't know who he is he's
in this
this costume and you can't see him
number one number two
nobody as far as i'm concerned gets on
that plane
with guns other than u.s secret service
agents you can
sense sometimes that there's a problem
without even being able to articulate
that there's a problem
i will take a secret service agent any
day over
anything like that air force one is
actually the responsibility of the air
force
the air force protects the plane they
maintain the plane and when the
president isn't on the plane
they actually do security for it members
of the air force are
allowed on the plane members of the
staff are allowed on the plane
and secret service agents are allowed in
the plane i have access to my weapons we
have access to all our weapons i mean we
need our weapons on the plane
and we have other weapons aside from the
ones that we personally carry
that we haul on and off the plane
yes you can use your weapon on the plane
however you have to be
very very careful when you do use that
weapon you have to be super careful
super accurate because if you miss
you could blow a hole into the side or
a portion of the plane which could then
cause a serious problem to the aircraft
itself
i'll give it a one i only give it a one
for just certain technical aspects as
far as like the way the limo's pulling
up
the way the plane is positioned
consider this my resignation so how
suspicious should you be of your
colleagues
i was in the u.s secret service for over
12 years i was never suspicious of my
colleagues
not in this level to be a double agent
to get
into the u.s secret service as a double
agent
that is not an easy thing to do so
here's the thing there's a hiring
process a
very very involved hiring process
a hiring process with multiple layers of
protection of security so that
somebody like that cannot get in
they do such a deep dive an intense
background investigation on you if
you're talking background checks you're
talking about interviewing people's
families
their schools going through their
history their previous jobs their
employers polygraph tests i used to give
polygraphs and assess people on the
veracity
of the truthfulness of what they were
saying in their application
to have an agent pull their gun out and
shoot one of their brothers and sisters
i can't see that i really can't i have a
bit of a hard time with the scene
because we see
jamie foxx the president going down into
this bunker
number one let me just say jamie foxx
the president is not the one clearing
the way in getting access to the bunker
his team his secret service agents if
there were to be a bunker
they're the ones clearing the way making
sure he can get in we're talking about
the white house we're talking about
a lot of secret service agents not just
agents but uniform division it is highly
unlikely again i never want to say never
but if not
impossible where the whole team is
taking out and you have channing tatum
some member of the public show up to end
up protecting the presidents of the
united states probably impossible
as far as your protective being able to
protect themselves
their job is not to take self-defense
their job is not to learn
self-defense and so that's why the
secret service is there
you're not there to teach them
self-defense you're there to do the
self-defense
for them i would give it
a zero mr president what the hell step
away from the windows please okay you
know what i'm gonna have to call you
back
back away three shots were fired from
the street at least one of them hitting
the press briefing room
we've got the suspect in custody as well
as a high-powered drive was anyone in
the room
if there is any type of shooting at the
white house
the last place i would want to go to to
have a nice discussion
with the president about the shooting is
in the oval office
oval office is glass there's doors
there's windows it's open it's exposed
although it is protected it is commonly
known that it is not a truly secure area
when the president is at the oval office
there are always
secret service agents they are outside
and they are inside
i would give this a one on a scale of
one to ten just simply for the fact that
you truly would never have a
conversation with your protectee like
that
when shots were just fired in such close
proximity
i'm back i'm back back i don't got a
problem with you
you hit this kid who have problems with
me all right i'm gonna have problems
with everybody
so why don't you just let the kid go
i've actually protected
children uh of a president a specific
child i was assigned to
now my first question is where is
everybody else where's the team
you're never alone with just the
protectee even if it's a child you have
a team
i really would be mindful as to who i
allow in close proximity of my protectee
usually people that they know very well
are allowed access to them
people that are vetted are allowed
access to them
look around calm down i'm all full of
people man they're shopping huh that
women got children
you don't want to shoot anybody i might
spend time distracting the person
but i'm not going to sit and negotiate
with you i'll distract you and talk to
you so that
my teams can come in from behind and
take you out so that i can
regain control of my protectee and keep
my protectees safe i might give this one
a 5.
[Applause]
so we have kevin costner protecting a
celebrity
this isn't uncommon actually a lot of
secret service agents when they retire
they typically end up going into some
form of private security
he's on stage but i'm trying to figure
out exactly where he is but typically
he's supposed to be
on stage but in the back either stage
right or stage left
the other issue is you have people on
stage with her
definitely a huge huge no-no there's
nobody that's going to be on stage
because as we see
she gets ambushed again you want to make
sure that when you're an agent
you there is nothing and i mean nothing
between
you and your protectee
[Applause]
[Music]
interestingly enough where you see the
other security person tell wave him to
come
to him your evacuation point should not
be through the crowd it should not be
through where the front doors are i want
an
exit that is away from everyone i want
an exit that nobody uses
the proper thing to do is she's behind
you as so long as she can move
she's behind you you're creating the
shield and you're using your hands and
you're pushing people away
and then you're going out you really
don't want her or anything in your hands
that's why
even if you see bad weather outside and
it's raining you'll
never see an agent holding an umbrella
you'll never see an agent even holding
bags or anything in their hands hands
are the most important thing these are
your weapons this is your defense
system and if there's something in your
hands how can you actually
fight and protect someone this not being
a true
secret service protectee i mean i can
see how this can happen in real life i
would give this
a six you would want to take the
president
to an undisclosed safe location
keep him there for some time until
things have settled and then you can
figure out what to do next